let's go next to
is it uh nathan from green acres is that
right
uh yeah that's right i can't i spoke
with you before um a couple months ago
okay
last time we spoke i was running for
office but uh i didn't win got 41
percent of the first time candidate it's
all right all right but i did for
questions just two
um but first i just wanted to recommend
if you're going to use protein powder
you probably want to use it if you're
lifting just like protein powders like
if you want to get big but yeah no i was
kidding when i asked that i'm not really
looking to use protein powder
yeah yeah you look like a healthy
individual so you good thank
you um
but my first question is i feel like a
lot of the momentum is changing with the
midterms
i think florida is an excellent example
of this
um
i actually noticed this and nobody's
really talking about this but in the
democratic primary this time around
there were more people that voted than
people that voted in 2018 and that
surprised me because 2018 had more
candidates 2018 had was like supposed to
be a blue wave year
but we have more democrats voting now in
florida
uh we didn't really have a real
republican primary but i'm curious if
democrats do well in the primary this
time around or excuse me in the midterm
betterment wins in pennsylvania
the democratic senate candidate in
wisconsin wins
maybe even val demings and charlie chris
win that'd be great um
that would be great but where did
democrats go from there because they
have potentially expanded the majority
in the senate
i don't know so much about the house
i'll have some positive news for the
houses we have more progressives maxwell
alejandro frost from florida as well
but where do democrats go for the rest
of the binding administration from 2022
to 2024. i have no idea and i actually
spoke about that with congressman ro
khanna earlier in the week because
the way that republicans are going to
function is as follows if democrats
maintain the senate but lose the house
which is right now the most
statistically likely outcome even though
the momentum continues to shift
democrats will get obstructed by
republicans on everything they do other
than supreme court picks if biden gets
another supreme court pick they'll be
able to get it through but otherwise
republicans are going to stand in the
way of everything and then when it comes
2024 they'll say democrats did nothing
for you for the last two years thanks to
us but they won't say that you should
vote for a republican and you know even
in my conversation with ro khanna
he said well people won't fall for that
people will know i don't know i don't
know i'm not sure about that so i think
that's a very difficult scenario and i
don't really have an answer but i think
it's a likely one
yeah yup yup yup that makes sense that
makes sense and i guess my second
question i'll try to be quick with this
one is
have you ever considered speaking at
college campuses because
i've done it before i've done it before
yeah uh well would you want to do it
anytime soon uh fau florida florida so
here's the deal i'll be totally honest
and forthright with you so
i i don't do it for free right because
it's usually like three total days of
travel it often takes me away from the
show whereas which is how i make money
or i lose a weekend and especially now
with a baby at home
it's really got to be worth it for me to
do that and you know most colleges they
just don't really have the budget
yeah 100
yeah for conservatives they have great
budget for conservatives they'll bring
in ben shapiro and michael knowles and
they'll play pay out the wazoo but for
liberals they tend not to have the
budget
yeah no that's 100 reasonable i
appreciate the directness with that and
i appreciate your answer to my question
and i appreciate your content all right
thank you so much all right nathan from
greenacres great to hear from you we're
going to take the briefest of breaks so
if you're holding on to talk to me don't
hang up because i'm going right back to
the phones in a moment